what is going on everybody and welcome
to a quick mini series on web scraping
with beautiful soup 4 so by no means are
we going to cover everything you can do
with beautiful soup but we're going to
cover some of the more common use cases
before we go any further I do encourage
you to check out the documentation for
beautiful soup if what we cover here
isn't quite what you were hoping for you
can do a whole lot of stuff with this so
we're really just going to be scratching
the surface here now moving this aside
to get beautiful soup the first thing
you'll need to do is pip install ba
eautiful soup 4 and I already have it so
that's fine also you may need to do pip
install LX ml and then we have that
already as well so make sure you have
those 2 things as long as you do you're
good to go so to begin I have set up a
sample page on Python programming net
for us to work with
I'll put again the link in the
description if I forget someone remind
me and also sample code as always posted
on Python programming that Annette so
this is just a quick sample page with
some text list a table picture and the
Zen of Python so moving this over that's
the link that we're going to use again
just go to the description it's also
just parse me make horseface you see
what I did there
ok so anyway no one's letting import vs4
as BS this is because basically this way
you can kind of look at old code and
over time this will be still useful
because in the past it was ps3 anyway
yes now we're also going to import URL
Lib dot request just so we can actually
make a request so now the source or
sauce as the in-crowd calls it is going
to be URL Lib dot request dot URL open
and we want to open that link so for me
that's Python programming done it
/ parse me make parse base gonna get
sued for trademark okay dot read okay so
that's the source now anytime you have
source code so like when when you leave
you that page basically it's just
returning the source code so all this
and not necessarily as pretty as as this
is so so that's the source code and then
we can turn it into a beautiful soup
object by saying flowing soup equals BS
capital B ei eautiful capital S soup
what do we pass through the sauce and
you can just say that but we'll also go
ahead and be explicit about the parser
that we want to use we want to use that
L XML there's also like html5 Lib that
you could use but L XML we're going to
use so cool so first let's go ahead and
like let's just look like what are we
dealing with right now so save and run
that so as you can see it's just it's
just the HTML basically as we would
expect it what we're looking at it now
and it doesn't really look too much
different than if we were to print the
source so sauce okay so this one's a
little a little Messier we've got the
tabs in the new lines actually so anyway
but it looks very similar I guess brilli
is like this right so the soup looks
more like what we're seeing in the
browser anyway it turns it into a
beautiful soup object which then lets us
actually interact with the soup that's
the whole point of doing that so I'm
going to stop printing the sauce so one
thing we can do is we could do something
really simple like print soup title and
this gives us the title of the document
so in this case the title was Python
programming tutorials the other thing we
can do like if you want like soup title
you can get like the name from the tag
so that's the title tag no doubt but you
can also do like string and get the
string version there so python
programming tutorials so and we're going
to talk a little bit text should also
and we'll talk about this in the next
tutorial I think yeah so those who will
work and we'll explain in the next
tutorial what the difference is so
there's that and then we can also do the
following so we can get like specific
values like print su P now this is just
going to print the first kind of
paragraph element but let's do it so you
get that first okay it's a paragraph
class introduction oh hello this is a
bubble up okay but we can also do
something like this we can say print
soup dot bind all and then P for
paragraph tags so now we should find all
of the paragraph tags so we did so we
found a whole bunch of extra information
and really this page doesn't really have
too many paragraph tags so it's just
like a sample page but if you did this
on like a news website or something like
that you you get substantially more more
information I'm trying to find my mouse
there it is okay so there's that and
then also you can instead you could do
something like this let's actually will
come into space there that out so
instead we could say for paragraph in
soup dot find all P so for each
paragraph we could do something like
this we could print the paragraph like
this we'll just that for now but in most
cases you actually don't want the tag
right so you know you could use regular
expressions or something and get rid of
it
just like you could use regular
expressions to parse all this stuff but
in this case we can do dot string for
example and you'll see that we actually
got just a couple strings but we're
missing some things and appears that
they're being returned as none this is
because dot string returns a navigable
string as opposed to text which is just
going to return regular ol Unicode so
this role were actually returned
everything that you wanted but it's not
going to like basically the navigable
string will only work if you don't have
um child tags inside of it so these
first two had child tags this one just
didn't have any children tags so in by
child tags just in case anybody is not
following that if we go up to here
oh hello this is a wonderful page you
can see a wonderful look so it's
slightly different you might not be able
to tell on video but it is and I can
just do search real quick and we can see
that actually this has it's like
basically this paragraph tag has a child
tag within it that is a span it also has
some strong tags anyway in most cases
you're really just going to want not
Texas text maybe Texas nothing against
Texas okay so yeah so that's your
paragraph text now there is one more
thing that you can do like when you have
an entire document rather than just
going through and finding the paragraph
tags and then getting the text in
between them you can do something like
print soup dot get text and while we're
doing that let's just comment these
lines out okay so here you get basically
all of the text that's found on this and
you'll see that also we picked up these
n of Python text as well because
remember that while you probably don't
remember because she's going to break
the page but but on this page the Zenna
python is actually not in paragraph tags
it's encased in pre tags took a while to
zoom anyway
it's encased in pre tags not paragraph
tags so there are going to be times
where you're not going to get the
paragraph data I've even seen some
websites that don't even use paragraph
tags they use span tags so so don't
think that you're always going to get
away with like parsing for paragraphs
okay so there's that aside from like
finding all the paragraphs another thing
that you can do is find all of the links
so for example you might say for URL in
soup in souped-up find all and we're
going to look for all
each or a tags and then we can say print
well to start with a print URL and let's
just print that out just to see what we
got okay so we get the entire tag as
we've been seeing basically every time
and so you might think okay here's what
I'll do I'll do text cuz I'm smart
cookie and then you find out oh shoot no
that doesn't work because that's the
text of the tag so instead what you'll
do is you RL get and we want to get the
reference so it's ref there boom now you
have your actual links okay so here you
go okay so those are just some some
quick basics of beautifulsoup that might
actually be enough for you at this point
but if it's not in the next tutorial
we're going to talk a little bit more
about some more slightly advanced
features of beautifulsoup and kind of
navigating around because especially if
paragraph data is not the only thing
that you want so stay tuned for that if
you have any questions comments concerns
whatever leaving below otherwise see in
the next tutorial